- What are good and effective
ways to collect information
on a company?
So from my time working as a consultant
and later as a project lead at McKinsey,
I want to share my insights,
my tips and tricks on exactly
this topic of company research,
which I hope will be helpful
for many of you as well.
These techniques will prove very helpful
if you're currently
preparing for job interviews,
or maybe you already
signed a labor contract
and are preparing for
the first days, weeks,
or months at your new employer.
This info will also be
relevant if you're a consultant
who wants to prepare for a new project,
for new client and
wants to get up to speed
with this new company in a faster way.
So welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel Firm Learning,
my name is Heinrich
and on my channel I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So with no further ado, let's get into it.
And today I want to
share with you four tips,
what you can do to do
some company research.
And all these tips have
in common that first
you can do them from home.
Second you don't need any
access to any databases.
So it's pretty much for free.
And third it's very easy and
straight forward to do that.
So also no significant
time investment required.
And stick until the end
because especially the last two
I think are quite juicy and important.
So make sure you're not missing them.
And the first step is to
read the news on the company
and while this might
seem a little bit obvious
you would be surprised
how many people I talk to,
also I work with were not
even aware about the last news
publications about a client for instance,
that we just started working for.
And now to go a bit beyond the obvious,
let me share two specific
tools that you can use to
really simplify and
facilitate this news research.
The first tool is the
Google News platform.
So this is a search machine from Google
specifically dedicated to news.
So if you're typing in
the name of your company,
here you will likely
find much better results
regarding the news than if you
just type in the company name
in the overall Google search bar,
because here are all search
articles that you get
are news articles indeed.
The second is Google alerts,
and this is pretty cool
because here can define
a search term and whenever
there's a new search result
on Google popping up for the
term, you would get an alert.
For instance an email
that Google sends you
with the overview of all the
new articles that came out.
And here you can also tailor
this to decide whether you
want to have this really live whenever
something new comes in,
or whether you want to have
a collection of results
once a day or once per week.
Depending on how common
your search term is
you might want to go for
the one or the other.
But this is really something
I would recommend you to do
also for your current employer,
or maybe also your current client project
that you are doing.
Make sure that you have
a Google alert activated,
and this can also be
pretty cool for your team.
So imagine you are a consultant.
Your partner has a meeting
with a board member
later that afternoon,
and you have the Google alert
activated and get the news.
So there's a new article that
was released in the local
press of where the company is from.
Here it can be a pretty cool
move to be the one who first
knows about this, shares
the article with the team,
with the partner,
and then helping the partner
to have a great meeting
with the board member,
because now the partner has an icebreaker
and maybe the article is
even about a difficult topic,
a difficult situation that
the company is facing.
You're for sure it would be important
for your senior leadership,
for your partners to be
aware of what's currently
going on at the client.
And this can be a little
piece of enabling that.
Next tip is to read the
annual report of that company.
So if you're not aware an
annual report is a report
that every publicly traded
company needs to release
once per year.
At least in most countries
where they give an overview
about their business activities,
their financials, their strategy.
It's really super insightful
and a great source of information.
You can usually find annual
reports in the investor
relations section of
the company's website,
or if you just Google annual
report plus the company name,
usually it will directly pop up.
Information that's typically
included in these reports
are information on the
overall company strategy.
Some key business results
that were achieved,
future focus initiatives,
what the company wants to
accomplish in the future
and report on industry trends
and business risks that
the company is facing,
information on personnel
and also remuneration of these people.
And also basic financial, such
as profit and loss statement,
cashflow statement, balance sheet,
and often also all types
of other pro-forma ratios.
These reports are usually
extremely detailed
and really a great source of
information also with info
on competitors, on
overarching industry trends.
So definitely something that
can inspire many other types of
analysis that you also do.
Next is a tip which is maybe
the most insightful one
and can give you access to information,
which is not that easily
found for instance
when just Googling certain things.
But before we dig into this
let me introduce you to
the sponsor of this
week's video, DataCamp.
DataCamp is an online learning platform,
where you can improve your
data and editor skills.
And you know that this
is something I talk about
all the time.
This is really a crucial
part of your skill set
if you want to succeed
in any consulting role
and I trust in many roads in industry,
and for sure in banking as well.
With DataCamp there are no
previous data skills needed
to get started, you can
learn from things as basic as
Excel 101 to more
advanced technical things
like for instance database
manipulation in SQL.
So for sure if the things that
I show you here in this video
are over your head,
you really have no idea
what this is all about,
there are some also very
introductory courses on Excel
in DataCamp which I trust can help you.
They have over 300 courses
with impact of learning,
and you can also learn on
the go with the mobile app
that they have.
Personally I very much like
the introduction to SQL course
which already helped me several
times on my own projects
when I needed to interact with databases.
So give it a try and I trust
that working with DataCamp
indeed can fast track
your data analysis skills
and these for sure are so
crucial in any consulting role,
but also many other related roles as well.
So if this piqued your interest
and you would like to try our DataCamp
then invest in yourself.
Check out DataCamp via the link in
the video description and
you will get access to
the first chapter of every
single course for free.
But let's continue.
And as I said, the next tip
I find especially insightful
and this is leveraging
local business registers.
Because while annual reports are great
they're often only available
really for the largest
publicly traded, publicly
listed companies.
But even for the smaller ones
many of them need to
release business information
on a regular basis.
And this is exactly what
you can get access on
on these local business registers.
These registers will have different names
in different countries.
In Germany for instance
it's the Bundesanzeiger.
But usually if you just
type company register
and then your country into Google,
you will likely find the
name of the company register
of your country and then can
search for it in a similar way.
Similar to annual reports
these company registers often
contain information on financials.
They often contain the last audit reports.
They might contain information
on the ownership structure
on the management team
and an employee figures.
Often this information
is less detailed than
in the annual reports and
the wealth of information
that needs to be released often
depends on the company size.
So you often have different
levels of detail available
depending on which type of company
exactly you're looking at.
And what makes these registers
even more powerful is that
nowadays there are all types
of meta registers or types of
meta search machines that have
connections to have run of
these local country registers
and then combine all the information.
So for the EU for Europe it's
for instance NorthData.com.
You can just type in the name of a person
or type in the name of a company,
and you get all types of information
also from different countries here.
So if you're ever interested for instance
in the business activity of
any of your family members
or relatives or friends,
you can just type in the
name of that person into
for instance NorthData.com
and you see all the companies
they are affiliated to,
wherever they're managing
director on similar positions.
This is all the information
that you will have.
So just for demonstration purposes
probably most of you will
know the YouTuber Ali Abdaal.
Ali if you're watching this,
love your content, great channel.
So if you just try out typing
his name into NorthData,
you see now all the
companies that he has founded
to set up his businesses,
but of course you can also do
this with actual companies.
So for instance you could type in Zeeman's
and then really get access
to a plethora of information
that I trust to really help
you to understand what exactly
happened with this
organization in the past,
what was going on and do
some research based on that.
Last but not least let's
talk about the importance of
researching industry trends.
So here I trust it's not even
that difficult to do that.
You can just type the industry of interest
plus industry trends in
the Google search bar,
and then get all types of reports.
As stated earlier you can
also use annual reports
to really get this information,
read what the company themselves
are writing about this.
So I rather want to talk
about why this is so great
and why this is so important.
And from my experience researching
industry trends are great
icebreakers in conversations with clients.
So for instance in the
construction industry,
which is the industry
that I currently work in,
there's at the moment a
huge shortage of wood.
So let's imagine you're
a consultant or working
for a construction company.
So in one of the first
meetings with your clients
you could ask them you know
there's this huge shortage
in wood, how is this affecting
your company at the moment?
What does this mean to you?
This can really be a great
icebreaker for your conversation.
And the best thing is
that things like this
also portray you as knowledgeable.
If you openly talk about
industry trends like this,
surely you know something
about the industry,
surely you're more than
just the young graduate
fresh out of university who has no clue
what he or she is doing, right?
So these are the little
tricks that help you in
conversations with clients.
Researching the industry,
being able to share little bits
and pieces like this can
really make the difference
in how you're perceived by your clients
and are able to beat client relationships.
But now let me hear from you.
What is your advice on
how to do company research
in a straightforward way?
Trust your insights will help not only me,
but everyone else in the Firm
Learning community as well.
So please leave a comment
with your insights
in the comment section.
As always if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel
and turn on notifications
to stay up to date
on all my content.
I once again want to give a
shout out to the sponsor of this
week's video DataCamp.
If you're interested in DataCamp,
check out the link to them
in the video description.
And of course also big
thanks to all the members of
Firm Learning for your support.
If you want to hear even more from me,
I'm also present on LinkedIn, Twitch,
Instagram, and Tik Tok.
Links to all of them in
the video description.
I'm Heinrich, I'm releasing new
videos every single Saturday
here on Firm Learning.
Looking forward to seeing
you again next week.
Until then bye-bye.